the fox news
near satire i mean it seems like satire
about gas prices declining
is taking on
even more uh comedic proportions
the new headline on fox news during a
segment about gas prices which are down
and i'm going to talk to you about that
is
white house takes a victory lap on a 50
cent decline in gas prices
and fox reporters
and commentators
bemoaning and criticizing joe biden what
now biden's bragging for the fact that
gas prices are down well listen if you
blame him for gas prices being up
wouldn't you give him some credit for
gas prices being down and this is a
circular
circular firing squad of sorts as old as
certainly this show has been going on if
you've got a democratic president and
you're a democrat and gas prices go up
you often say there's no connection
between the president and gas prices but
if it's a republican you say oh the
republicans to blame for the gas price
is going up flip it gas prices go down
and you don't like the guy or gal in the
oval office well uh you don't give them
any credit for that however if your guy
or gal is in the oval office and gas
prices go down you go look at the great
job that they're doing now i don't do
that
i respect you too much
to play that game with you
i've regularly told you
presidents have almost nothing to do
with gas prices and we will get to that
but
that being said
it cannot be denied
that gas prices are down and they're
down quite significantly if you actually
take a look after peaking at five
dollars and two cents per gallon
nationally
uh they are now down to 449. that is
indeed a 53 cent decline it's about 11
percent i mean gas is still high there's
no denying that but it is a significant
significant decline
what can presidents do
what can presidents do to impact gas
prices there's basically three things
one is invade a country that has a bunch
of oil
and essentially take it steal it and use
it and then use that to introduce it
into the market and it presumably based
on the laws of supply and demand should
reduce gas prices at least to some
degree number two do a gas tax holiday
gas tax holiday will temporarily uh
lower the price of gas and people can
stock up on gas if they want if there's
no limit on how much you can buy and
number three is tap into the strategic
petroleum reserve strategic petroleum
reserve
can um
depending on who you ask lower gas
prices temporarily between 12 and 18
cents per gallon some people say up to
25
slightly different numbers depending on
who you ask those are the things the
president can do but if you're fox news
and you've been playing the gas prices
up is all thanks to biden to some degree
don't you have to give them credit
credit for prices going down and just
imagine the fox news editorial meeting
okay
we can't talk about rising gas prices
anymore any other ideas how about this
let's slam that they're coming down too
quickly
that it will hurt gas stations
and that joe biden is being
braggadocious about it
that's what they did that's what they're
doing when fox news starts complaining
that the gas prices are falling too
quickly you start to know something's
wrong and uh it wouldn't surprise me to
see a headline like
did joe biden lower gas prices
to distract
from hunter biden's laptop i haven't
seen that
that's imaginary
but it wouldn't surprise me what we did
see and i'm not joking by the way about
the gas stations thing we looked at this
last week here's fox news bemoaning
lower gas prices because mom and pop gas
stations could be hurt i
want him to run again
and the rest probably don't that is
stunning by the way on gas prices i
found it curious i was at a lacrosse
tournament up in wilmington delaware
over the weekend in delaware and
northern maryland regular gas is about
anywhere from 455 to 480 a gallon so the
price is beginning to creep back down it
is it is and the point was made over the
weekend i believe it's a wall street
journal that gas prices are actually
coming back down historically faster
with the price of oil than usual oh they
might be coming down too quickly this
goes to show you what an incredible risk
reward calculation has to happen on the
part of those small independently owned
most of them mom and pop gas stations
it's a struggle for all of them now
that's not really true and there's a
bunch of different things that go into
that just to quickly refresh your memory
without going back into it
first
gas stations make very little off of
selling gas that's number one and number
two
their margin is very similar whether gas
prices are high or low right i mean if
your markup is on average seven to ten
cents per gallon if you sell it for five
bucks a gallon you make seven to ten
cents per gallon and if you sell it for
two bucks a gallon you make seven to ten
cents per gallon
sometimes high gas prices are actually
bad for gas stations when gas prices are
really high
you will sometimes see gas stations eat
a little bit of the cost
they will accept if everybody's
accepting a seven cent profit you might
see a gas station go you know what we
make more from the slurpees and the ring
dings and the honey buns and the entire
thing
so
we're going to just eat some of this
price increase to be the cheapest in the
area we'll just accept like a two cent
profit on gas or maybe just no profit to
get people in buying the higher uh
higher margin stuff so not only are
higher gas prices not necessarily good
for local gas stations sometimes they're
actually bad but fox news won't tell you
that they'll just say oh no what is joe
biden irresponsible for so quickly
lowering gas prices but it's also
nothing that he did but if he did it
then it's bad give me a break guys we'll
have this clip on our instagram you can
find us on instagram at david pakman
show see you there
if you're using traditional toilet paper
and paper towels you're probably cutting
down trees from north american old
growth forests and i've talked about
before we don't want to be doing that
also they come wrapped in single-use
plastic that's also a mess and the
solution is real paper this is a sponsor
i feel great about real paper makes
paper towels and toilet paper from fast
growing bamboo not from virgin tree
fibers from forests using bamboo
prevents soil erosion it prevents
habitat loss and importantly
it's a major impact on carbon real paper
also uses no plastic packaging so we
often talk about what can we do
corporations need to do many things but
what can we do to help the environment
this is an easy thing and i made the
switch to real paper at home i can't
tell the difference everybody buys
toilet paper everybody buys paper towels
this is one you can actually feel good
about and you can use the code pacman
for 30 off your first shipment when you
sign up for a subscription at
realpaper.com
pacman the link is down below